[Music]
I come from a real simple background a
mom cleaned houses my dad was a navy
mechanic
they both emigrated from Mexico in the
first of my family to graduate from
college just considering where I come
from and where I'm at today every day
that I wake up and get to do something
here in this space is like a blessing so
I don't take it for granted and just
looking for something more in the
day-to-day more than just a business
challenge
I'm Arnulfo Ventura I'm the CEO of bean
fields I've been in the food and
beverage industry for the last 12 years
and that used to be class of 2008 what I
learned the most from the GSB that still
serves me well today it's that it's the
answer to that question that everybody
has to answer to in the process of
applying to just B's what matters to you
most and why and not losing sight of
that
[Music]
being filled as a company that started
in 2010 and it was ultimately founded
with the idea of making it better for
you or th up a chance to provide an
alternative for corn and so our products
are made from a composition navy bean
black bean and brown rice think of a
Doritos but perhaps healthier still a
small company in the neighborhood around
16 direct employees a larger extended
force in the hundreds but all 16 of
those members aren't doing the same job
they were doing 12 months ago each and
every one of them is doing something
more acting at an elevated position or
even taking on additional roles and
responsibilities that are setting them
up for their next kind of professional
step or our developments brand and taste
come before everything else taste has to
absolutely be there but the brand has to
pop enough at the Shelf which you have
to do really closely is listen to what
the consumer wants because a consumer
has the power and the consumer will be
sure with their dollars to vote one way
or another but they'll signal what they
want
so what lured me to bean field
specifically it was just the fact that
it was on a downward trajectory that
they had already taken a couple swings
at it with other leaders and that it
quite hadn't gotten there so it's like
yeah let me let me try that see if that
seems like a worthy challenge and wait
there's also these other aspects to it
the B Corporation aspect the partnership
with farmers in North Dakota and
continue to promote conventional and
organic farming now the social impact
side the fact that we get to partner
with nonprofit homeboy industries
that's hoping to rehabilitate previously
incarcerated gang members and when you
leave in all those pieces it certainly
makes working here fulfilling but I
think those are key components for that
most brands are aspiring to include
today and
being a food and beverage bread so it's
it's been some time since I've graduated
from the GSB fast forwarding to today
and what matters to me most hasn't
changed I think the tools and the
experiences that I picked up at the GSB
helped keep that in perspective for me
and there are certainly hard skills I
think the one that probably serves me
the most certainly interpersonal
dynamics you know the business part of
business is easy it's the people part
that's always a challenge three core
things that come to mind that stick with
me till this day it's how you treat
people hard work ethic and take pride in
your craft
[Music]